[Gelächter]
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt die erdbeerzeit ist er für mich so
meine lieblings zeit und ich habe schon
einige etwa rezepte hochgeladen heute
gibt es eine erdbeer tiramisu ein ganz
einfaches und schnelles aber ein sehr
schönes als ich habe auch schon ein etwa
rhabarber tiramisu das habe ich
hochgeladen ich habe auch immer kokos
tiramisu und in ganz ganz ganz altes
rezept für ein erdbeer tiramisu da war
ich damals sogar glaube ich im
küchenstudio weil ich noch keine eigene
küche hatte ist ein richtig altes video
heute machen wir ein schönes etwa
tiramisu ich nehme dafür so eine eckige
glasform ihr könnt jede beliebige form
nehmen die ihr möchtet ihr könnt auch
einzelne kleine gläser anrichten wenn er
sagt es soll direkt schon portioniert
sein also da dürft ihr einfach ganz frei
entscheiden ich zeige euch heute einfach
mal so eine gestaltungsmöglichkeit die
ich ganz schön find sodass und erdbeer
tiramisu trotzdem eben schön ist das
entbehrt tiramisu wird ohne ei sein es
wird ohne kaffee sein das heißt es wird
einfach nur schön lecker und fruchtig
und cremig und ich glaube das schmeckt
einfach alles was ihr tun könnt um das
ganz aufzupeppen wenn er sagt das wird
so eine erwachsenen party könnt ihr
gerne auch ein bisserl schuss dazu geben
als barry zum beispiel ich glaube das
bacardi mit drin weißer rum oder
irgendwie so das könnt ihr gerne in der
erdbahn maßnahmen geben aber so ist es
einfach ein richtig leckeres fruchtiges
dessert vereine ja das erste was wir
euch zeigen weiter ich zeige euch mal
die zutaten für die erste schicht dafür
neben dir 250 gramm löffelbiskuits 500
gramm erdbeeren da habe ich bereits ist
grün entfernt etwas vanille extrakt und
zitronenschale und zitronensaft oder
nehmt einfach etwas zu thronen passte
jetzt erstmal etwa pury herstellen das
heißt hier die erdbeeren rein und damit
vanille extrakt und zitronen passte
verwechseln
[Musik]
sieht super aus stell dich kurz zur
seite und macht gleich noch die
mascarpone creme dafür verwende ich 250
gramm was capone 60 gramm puderzucker
250 quark vanille extrakt und zu drohnen
passte 400 gramm sahne und sonderbar zum
steif schlagen jetzt nimmt die dem
ascona den puderzucker und quark und
verrohte zutaten also das geht wirklich
einfach ich finde es immer nur wichtig
beim ask ab ohne dass man die einfach
zuerst mal verrührt weil die ansonsten
bisschen klumpp deswegen hier einfach
kurz hören
und wenn ihr das ganze so ein bisschen
leid machen wollt also jetzt sagt okay
das heißt tiramisu aber wir wollen so
ein bisschen weniger kalorien dann könnt
ihr hier auch auf den puderzucker
verzichten oder ihr könnt zum beispiel
auch stadt mascarpone mal quark nehmen
oder eben in joghurt dann wird das ganze
auch ein bisschen leichter also ich
finde da kann man schon mal auch gucken
oder auch statt sahne einfach ein
bisschen joghurt aber das schmeckt zwar
sehr gut schmeckt wirklich gut aber
später das aufspritzen mit dem
spritzbeutel geht dann nicht so gut dass
musste halt überlegen aber so für zum
essen ließ auch lecker mit joghurt das
machen wir auch ganz oft das machen will
extrakt und zitronen passte rein
jetzt früheren sahne zugießen und mit
seiner partei schlagen und wie gesagt
weniger keinem sprits beide benutzen
volt braucht ihr auch kein sander
partnern können das einfach so verrühren
hab ich
das nämlich jetzt schon mal einen
spritzbeutel und nehmen hier so eine
große feige sagte stern.de damit werde
ich nämlich die oberfläche schön
dekorieren dann immer die spitze so
bisschen umknicken da kommt unten
nämlich nichts raus
und dann könnt ihr zwei drittel der
creme hier in dem spritzbeutel reingeben
den rest lasse ich da drin
der spritzbeutel kann erstmal zur seite
und dann habe ich jetzt hier in der
großen glasschüssel weg sagt und meine
löffelbiskuits die kann ich jetzt hier
schön rein dekorieren verein schichten
und wenn es nicht passt einfach ein
bisschen zerbrechen
dann passt ihr auch noch hier rein
und dann wird es jetzt schön geschichtet
jetzt kommt die hälfte des apps da rein
[Musik]
und damit einer palette verteilen
es zählt jetzt schönen löffelbiskuits 1
da kommt jetzt die creme drauf die
verstreiche ich jetzt so ein bisschen da
muss man sich jetzt keine mühe machen
mit dem spritzbeutel
und ich gebe dann noch erdbeeren mit
rein einfach so als schöne geschichte
könnte jetzt gerne vom grün befreien und
dann so ein bisschen vierteln oder
achteln oder auch gerne in scheiben
schneiden was immer die folgen mit dem
flexi kath da können die kinder immer
ganz gut helfen
[Musik]
und dann noch eine zweite schicht
gesetzt sich gleich auch noch ein
bisschen also jetzt sieht es zwar ein
bisschen zu hoch ausarbeitung setzt sich
gleich noch
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier noch mal schön die
erdbeer soße drauf und dann tue ich die
restliche creme schön auf die oberfläche
[Musik]
jetzt drehe ich den spritzbeutel hier zu
halten senkrecht und dann wirklich
schöne tupfen draufsetzen weil sie das
nicht machen wollt einfach mit einem
löffel oder mit einer palette
verstreichen aber ich finde es macht so
schon den unterschied oft so ein
standard terrorismus oder richtig schön
ist die rams
[Musik]
was
genau richtig so und jetzt
der chor ich nur so eine kleine ecke und
dann ist es nämlich schon fertig das
heißt also zwei halbiert
eine dritte halbe
kris peeters sind so kleine kekse die
mit weißer kuvertüre überzogen sind die
den ich jetzt hier auch mit drauf
ein bisschen gefriergetrocknete
erdbeeren
einfach so drüber bröseln
und wenn ihr wollt noch mit weißer
schokolade kleine röllchen abziehen
[Musik]
und falls es therapie so nicht gleich
gegessen wird dann einfach die erdbeeren
noch bisher mit tortenguss zum sprühen
einfach besprühen ansonsten könnte die
erdbahn aber auch kurz vorher drauf
sitzen nur damit sie nicht austrocknen
und halt nicht schlecht werden
und bevor ich es jetzt aber sehr weh
dass ich erstmal zwei stunden im
kühlschrank abgedeckt ronan ok abdecken
ist es schwierig welche tupfer so hoch
gesetzt habe aber ich lasse jetzt mal
zwei stunden im kühlschrank ab ja mich
aufgedeckt ruhen ihr solltet am besten
abdecken damit einfach dass etwa ein
bisschen diese löffelbiskuits einziehen
kann und sie ein bissel aufweichen und
dann probieren wir uns gleich
[Musik]
jetzt ist das tier so fertig und ich
würde mal sagen ich ruft hoger und
jasmin dazu zum probieren
[Musik]
ja komm schubert hoch tiramisu probieren
ja
aufzug bekommt viel schneller
wachsen lieber wieder wegschicken für
das die anderen kälte auf die hand
machen
[Musik]
ja
super ich etwas mitgebracht und zwar
haben wir heute ein angebot in unserem
online shop es gibt 20 prozent auf dem
spritzbeutel ständer und auf weitere
andere produkte echt jetzt ja einfach so
jetzt ist es raus habe ich jetzt einfach
raus aber ja dann sind ein paar flecken
[Musik]
brauchen lappen
der stadt mit
naja fast
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wirklich das aufheben ja vielleicht
probiere
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja aber das machen wir wirklich wir
bereiten jetzt einfach ein code 1
siegtor von jasmin einfach nur 20
prozent gesenkt
und das war und ich hab's rausgekramt
aus dem keller
da wo andere zum lachen so wirke
[Musik]
das erste stück ist immer nett so schön
zum rausholen aber die nächsten sind
umso schöner
richtig
war und dass leichte
schnittverletzungen ja
sagen
[Musik]
ja richtig gut also probiert das rezept
gerne aus mir geht es noch der keller
aus mischt schon aus rein wer weiß was
da noch so finden für euch
zurück findet ihr in meiner app und auch
sadismus blog.de viel spaß dabei bis zum
nächsten mal
auf zu ihrem nochmal rein zu dritt ja
das geht ja
gut los geht's
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
stop
[Musik]
perfekt